you know i have the great privilege of
regularly speaking
to senator ted cruz because we have this
show together verdict
with ted cruz which you can get on apple
podcast you get it all over the place so
we talk about things that are really
important you know national security
and the presidential debate and the
supreme court in the constitution we
talk about all that stuff right
but i now have to invite senator cruz
on this show because i need some
personal advice here you see
the senator has a book coming out it
just came out actually this week
one vote away about the crucial supreme
court cases that were decided by one
vote senator has a lot of personal
insight into that
i am trying to write a book right now
and it's it's not my first
book but it's my first book with words
and so
i'm kind of struggling with it i i want
to get some advice senator cruz
thank you so much for coming on the show
to help me out well i i'm glad to be
here for
for the the writers workshop where we're
doing together
well i i just i don't want to waste any
time so i want you to know
i know how to make a book cover i
understa i've done that
and i know how i can click the enter bar
the return
key and go all the way down but so we
can skip that part
how do you do the part with the words
well look i i i do have to confess to
you
that that actually yesterday you kind of
hurt my feelings
so how did i do that well you and i
filmed
a verdict podcast yesterday and we were
talking about the book on
on the podcast and you told told
everyone you said you were in the
process
of reading my book which for those who
listen precisely the language
means you haven't read the damn book
you know i mean and i just want to be
clear
i've read your book every single
word of your book i've read it's true
that's true and i
i appreciate that you're a better friend
than i am you're a better
reader than i am and i ha i have to tell
you something
i i think probably i'm going to take
more time
to read your book than you took to read
my book because i say this
all joking aside it's a very interesting
book
usually senator politician books uh you
know maybe books written by some of your
colleagues they're a little
they're a little thin you know it's
always like it's like the courage to be
courageous and the leadership to be a
leading leader and
they're just they're kind of about
nothing but this book is actually about
something it's about
these pivotal cases that you have have
worked on
in in your careers you actually have
personal insight into it
and then of course the most important
issue probably in this whole
presidential campaign
has become this open supreme court seat
well you're right that politician books
are usually
vapid and and a little thin is is giving
them too much credit it reminds me of
on the simpsons kodos and kang the space
aliens when they're campaigning
and and they they they lay out their
platform as upwards
not downwards forwards not backwards and
twirling
twirling into the future
that's about it that is the substance of
most of those books
so i i do think the book uh
has at least a little more than kodos
and kang um
look i mean the book this is this was a
labor of love i wrote it this spring and
summer
and and it's uh while we were on uh
covet lockdown i was sitting in my
living room pulled out the laptop and
and wrote it
and it focuses on the us supreme court
which is you know
a lot of my life what i did before i was
in the senate was
argue cases at the supreme court that
was that was my career
and uh every chapter talks about
a a different constitutional right and
uh and i tell war stories i talk about
talk about what the cases were about the
big cases what the stakes were and
and the inside what's going on at the
court who the justices are
um and and really try to bring
people behind the curtain
uh to understand what's going on and so
it was
it was a lot of fun writing um obviously
when i was writing it this spring and
summer i had no idea we'd have a vacancy
right now i knew we had an election
coming up in november and the plan was
release it
right before the election to underscore
the stakes of the election
i have to admit i'm i'm a little worried
that i wrote about about
one vote away and essentially a vacancy
on the supreme court and and it turns
around and happens
i will say this i'm really glad i didn't
write about thermonuclear war
[Laughter]
that is very true next book i suggest
you write
is about how i won the lottery or
something like that that could be that
could be great as well
i did notice during this presidential
debate if you could call it a debate i
don't know that i would call it a debate
but the one we saw this week
the first topic right out the gate was
about the supreme court
and even these issues of say court
packing which joe biden
couldn't answer his opinion on whether
or not they should pack the supreme
court
we were about to to see him stumble over
that give his non-answer
until of course the totally neutral
moderator chris wallace
jumped in for the first of seven million
times that night
and ran interference for joe biden did
you uh do you have any big takeaways
from either that segment or the rest of
the debate
um look i mean the whole debate was was
a mess
i think wallace was a train wreck as a
moderator
i i think he did um
as bad a job as any presidential debate
moderator has ever done
and and it's right up there with if you
remember back
when when obama and mitt romney were
debating and candy crowley
jumped in and corrected romney
incorrectly like like she stepped in and
said no you were wrong
and and she was wrong about what she was
correcting him that that that
wallace didn't do that but he was he was
petulant he was angry
he was sighing and laughing and and
doing all sorts of things look it's
obvious
he can't stand trump it's obvious
wallace is voting for joe biden
and you look at his question several of
his questions were basically just
oppo dumps yeah uh attacking trump
you know one of the ones on on the taxes
i have to admit i
i know firsthand because the new york
times two days before the debate comes
out with their breathless story about
trump's taxes
that whole story was written to be the
question at the debate which of course
wallace
happily obliges and and it's part of the
the game the media plays i thought it
was pretty ridiculous
it was ridiculous and i guess there's
actually a parallel here between
the courts and these moderators right
which is that the judges are supposed to
be
politically neutral i mean maybe they
have their own private political views
but they don't
let let it affect how they rule on the
bench
and the moderators of these debates are
also supposed to be
neutral at least in as much as they're
doing their job and yet in both cases
they have become so hyper partisan chris
wallace i believe is a democrat but he's
he's always you know been kind of
branded as fair
down the middle he's had an ostensibly
right-wing or somewhat conservative news
outlet
can you imagine how much worse it is
going to get from here if even
the moderate or even slightly
conservative debate
goes so far in joe biden's direction is
there any way to recover some
objectivity yeah look i've got to say
wallace has always been a liberal
democrat
and and people confuse it because he
works at fox news
um but but i mean he is happily on the
left side of the aisle and and
and and he regularly is is is willing to
be the hatchet man
with whatever attacks are directed at
conservatives he's been doing that a
long long time um you know the rest of
the debate
um i mean it was ugly there was a lot of
interrupting there was a lot of
insulting
i mean they were taking shots at each
other um
you know i guess you you told me you
opened your show today with with the
sound of goats screaming
yeah i wanted to give a seven second
recap of the 90-minute debate
and uh that seven second ring was just
goats screaming i felt it encapsulated
so michael i have to ask you how exactly
did you get that audio
well you see in show business senator we
never reveal our tricks
but i i will say that fewer goats were
harmed in the making of that clip
then americans were harmed watching that
largely pointless debate look actually
both sides had some good
good moments trump's best moment was
when he made the case that that
biden supports shutting down the economy
shutting down small businesses
destroying jobs shutting down schools
and that trump thinks we should open the
economy get people back to work get
people back to school
that was the best the best moment of the
whole debate
look biden was benefited and you and i
have talked about this quite a bit
by the really low expectations for biden
that a lot of people
had convinced themselves he had full-on
dementia and biden did fine i mean
biden's performance
didn't surprise me because i think the
right
overstated he's had some mental decline
but i don't think it's nearly as great
as
as some people have convinced themselves
so called it you predicted this on our
show
maybe three weeks ago you said we're
making a big mistake here because joe
biden is you know he's pretty tough
politician
and we're we're uh we're playing
expectations so low it's going to come
bite us and it seems
seems to have happened yeah no i i think
that's right and and biden took the
opportunity a couple of times to to help
himself like when he categorically came
out and said
i oppose defunding the police
that was helpful to him that that
actually moved the ball forward with him
now
shame on chris wallace for not calling
and calling him on it
um for for not pressing back and
actually
the the president trump could have done
a better job pressing back on that as
well he
he let let biden kind of wriggle away on
that
i i agree i they're now saying there
will be more
presidential debates there was some
question of whether biden was going to
throw in the towel and say we don't want
any more of these but i think as you say
he may have helped himself a little bit
during this past one
is there any advice you would give to
either the republicans broadly as we're
preparing for these debates
to the president to the moderators you
know
how would you like to see the second and
third debate play out
so look on moderators this is a long
time beef of mine
why the hell is every debate moderator
in the primaries in the general a
partisan democrat who will never
vote for the republican and we allow
this to happen
it actually it's an even bigger beef of
mine
during the primaries because we have
these lefty journalists
moderate republican primary debates i
don't know maybe it's a bigger beef of
mine because i didn't make it to the
general so it's the only one i
participated in
but the moderators are all a bunch of
people who are never going to vote in a
republican primary and
and and it seems to me if republicans
had any sense we would say
our primary debates will be moderated by
someone who will vote in a republican
primary and and
you know i don't know if you have a a
you know a sean hannity or a mark levine
or a michael knowles i mean i mean you
have lots of different uh moderators who
actually are
themselves thinking through some subset
of questions primary voters might be
thinking
and then in the general obviously you
couldn't have every moderator be
be a republican although we have every
moderator be a democrat right now in the
general but
i would settle for at least some of them
at least
you know some semblance of a balance
uh instead of just just having as
we saw last night the moderator play
play attack uh and be one-sided
of course i i used to say this and
people would would laugh at me i'd say
we should have rush limbaugh a moderated
debate they'd say oh my gosh you're so
crazy great
why is it so crazy rachel maddow does it
on the left why don't we have someone
who holds the opinions on the right i
agree i i i
rush would be fantastic and actually joe
joe rogan would be terrific i mean it's
the media hates that
and rogan endorsed bernie friggin
sanders i mean it's not like he's a
an arch conservative but but he would be
he would be a better choice than some of
the so-called journalists
who have done it historically absolutely
um there is so much more to cover
obviously uh but
we're gonna have to do that on the
verdict podcast we're gonna have to have
people go over
and subscribe on apple pie michael did i
mention i have a book oh wait hold on
did you write a book
hold on wait well you know i'm in the
process of reading it
so the book the book seriously it
actually is i it pains me to give
an earnest and sincere compliment
the book is really good it is an actual
worthwhile read i know everybody's so
busy these days
it is worthwhile it really puts into
focus this issue
of the supreme court which is the top
issue in the campaign
and then they'll be able to buy your
book and then we can keep the lights on
in the verdict studio and keep doing the
show
the that always helps i i do think it's
it's
it's interesting and people will learn
and and and
and it's not you know it's not a
kind of up in the clouds academic book i
mean it's designed to be you don't have
to be a lawyer you don't have to be a
constitutional expert it's designed
to try to make free speech in religious
liberty and the second amendment
u.s sovereignty and all of these issues
understandable to people and so it gets
into
to the substance of it but does it in a
way that that
i think people will learn and and feel
far better armed
uh at the water cooler i don't know what
the the zoom equivalent of the water
cooler is but but
the keyboard or your phone you're right
um
as we're debating 2020 and the elections
and and judge barrett and all of the
issues going up
i i think the the book will be helpful
to people and
and uh and you know what you can bundle
it and buy my book and your book
together
you can that's true and if it takes
let's say it takes i don't know six
hours or something to read your book
it'll take about six hours and ten
seconds to read both of our books
together
you'll you'll learn a lot you can double
your knowledge i do appreciate senator
in the book
that you don't need to be a
constitutional expert or a lawyer
to understand it because as as we've
pointed out i'm not even expert in
in writing a book i don't even know how
to do that so it is it is
very accessible very helpful i think and
this is going to be the central debate
and to be clear michael you're
underselling yourself because because
your book
is truly comprehensive and encyclopedic
it includes
every single conceivable reason to vote
for democrats
well thank you i appreciate the
compliment i think you're absolutely
right
and and so when you go out and buy
senator cruz's book
you know go buy my book too senator i'll
see you over on the set of verdict